floor is um it's like a special material
so i mean people have to wear these sort
of
blue shoe covers over a decade later
we're still discovering behind the
scenes secrets from the harry potter
franchise
today we're covering all the must-know
trivia from harry potter in the order of
the phoenix
how did the actors cause chaos on a
construction set
why did daniel radcliffe's scream have
to be silent
so that's your bit of knowledge for
today
[Music]
working on a movie in the harry potter
franchise means a lot of time on set
which also means a lot of time to fill
with activities and shenanigans
when shooting harry potter in the order
of the phoenix the cast had a variety of
activities to keep them busy when they
weren't learning potions and battling
the dark lord
when they weren't playing quidditch the
young wizards were outside playing
another sport
cricket that's right here we can see
matthew lewis and alfred enoch
sharpening up their cricket skills or
trying to at least we wonder how often
they took homework breaks
some in for one of the tutors which i
haven't done
daniel radcliffe and gary oldman didn't
just bond on screen
they spent quality time together
off-screen as well
how many films have you done
i've done last week now as for
nymphadora tonks actress
natalia tenna music was more her style
here she is in her trailer playing some
of her own original songs
evidently the cast is full of surprise
talents
it wasn't all fun and games though
remember that many of the actors were
still in school
and regularly needed to do homework the
team did take a planned 9-week break
from filming for daniel radcliffe and
emma watson
the two actors had to do some major
school exams i have worked
hard every single day that i was at that
school while the actors were working
they got to learn some new skills in the
wizarding world with
wand choreography since the fifth film
in the series incorporated a lot of high
level wand work
paul harris a dance choreographer was
brought in to teach the actors how best
to work with the styles and techniques
to really bring their wizarding to life
they had 5 basic moves to use with every
character adding their own special
touches to each according to their
personality
this work was definitely intense so much
so that many of the actors actually
wound up breaking their wands
resulting in them using rubber ones
instead which were more durable than the
wood
breaking the most ones throughout the
films i think i think is
about 10. at the time of this film the
record holder for the most wands broken
was devin murray who'd already gone
through
10 different wands wands can be very
dangerous business
and no one would know that better than
matthew lewis who suffered a perforated
eardrum after helena bonham carter
accidentally stabbed his ear with a wand
speaking of bonham carter
the actress happened to have some
enhancements for the movie
she'd had chicken fillet inserts to put
inside her bra while
shooting what's this rubbish what's this
rubbish she says
this could sort of be considered
character work
the weasley twins were always practicing
to up their trickery game
the actors were notorious for playing
little pranks on set
but one really blew them all away and
actually got the twins and their little
sister into a bit of trouble
there was a big construction site across
from a studio the movie was shooting in
and the weasley siblings weaseled their
way onto the site's
walkie-talkie channel there were plenty
of devices around the set so the actors
thought it would be fun to tell the
construction workers that they could go
home
and it probably was until
the gaffer caught them and gave them a
very good talking to
and say mischief managed otherwise
anyone can read it
there were some more laughs that
happened on set that weren't trick
related
those came around with the kissing
scenes remember how the trio giggled
throughout talking about
harry kissing cho we're sure harry's
kissing was more than satisfactory
all that was real the actors kept
cracking up and it was just so enjoyable
that the team kept the cameras rolling
and it made the final edit
it's no surprise considering there was
quite a build up
katie leung was pretty nervous about the
kiss and really prepared herself
mentally beforehand
but then when the planned shoot date
came the kiss had to wait because
radcliffe wound up being sick
daniel is a very good kisser when it
came to stunts
rupert grint had a pretty strange
experience when shooting the scene where
hermione throws ron across a room
usually there would just be a harness
but to really help show the stunt
realistically
grint was strapped to a much larger man
who was moving
up and down a ladder it is pretty hard
to think of harry potter without emma
watson ruper grint and daniel radcliffe
at the center of the movies but the fact
is
order of the phoenix was almost watson's
last film with the franchise
the actress had seriously considered
leaving the role so she could
concentrate on other pursuits
after taking some time to weigh the pros
and cons
watson felt that it would have been way
too strange to watch any other actress
play the role that she'd grown up doing
so she made the choice to stay until the
end we are
definitely glad she did i definitely
made the right decision
another gem from the wizarding world is
luna lovegood
it was the role of a lifetime for the
actress since she'd actually been a fan
of the series since she was eight years
old
and her favorite character was you
guessed it
luna well if i were you know who
i'd want you to feel cut off from
everyone else she got to bring a bit
more of herself to the role as well
the multi-talented actress actually made
the radish earrings that we see her
wearing
building the incredible settings we see
throughout the fifth film is extensive
and
always impressive sometimes it could
even be pretty dangerous
the ministry of magic building took 22
weeks to build
and was only on screen for about 10
minutes total
the set was of course rigged up to be
exploded
meaning if the cast had their cell
phones on set they could have
accidentally triggered it and blown the
set up
there were also some buildings that were
just too expensive to be in the movie
sirius black's london residence grimmeld
place was built by the film team
since the building they needed to shoot
in would have been too expensive
it says a lot considering the fact that
constructing a set like this
isn't that cheap either speaking of the
black family
this gorgeous family tree has the names
of over 70 different members of the
black family the jk rowling created for
the movie
i've never used the visitors entrance
before should be fun
the ministry of magic was brought to
life with two very different techniques
painted cardboard and full-on cgi while
pretty well
every setting in the movies is epic the
department of mysteries where this wild
battle takes place was
actually the very first shot in the
movies to be entirely created with cgi
we don't blame them considering how
major that cleanup would have been
a bit surprised the team didn't choose
to use cgi for the 30
000 individual tiles that were added to
the ministry set by hand
the so-called tiles were actually made
out of cardboard covered in
very thick paint as real tiles would
have been far too expensive
the ingenuity of the team doesn't stop
there though how does maddie moody
manage to ride a broomstick with a
prosthetic leg
especially customized broom instead of
the stirrups the other actors used actor
brendan gleason wrote a broom that had
posts at the front for his legs and a
seat for him to sit on
stay in formation everyone don't like
ranks one of our absolute favorite
references in the whole movie
has to be harry's nod to a beloved
character remus lupin
you know the very first time i saw you
harry i recognized you immediately
if harry's teaching fashion is familiar
then it's probably because it's very
closely modeled after the closed
professor lupin wore during harry potter
and the prisoner of azkaban radcliffe
brought the idea to his producers
because he thought it would be a good
way to pay respect to the professor he
looked up to so much
people like me
well let's just say that i'm used to it
right now
the creative choices in this film really
made it a standout
one in particular still manages to move
us every time we see it
harry's scream after sirius black passes
away
the choice to make the heartbreaking
moment silent was reportedly because the
actual scream recorded was so painful
that it made emma watson
and helena bonham carter actually cry we
can't even imagine watching and hearing
the scene in person
the original audio has still never been
released publicly
as for this terrifying moment the wacky
eye color change harry has is courtesy
of cgi
as opposed to contact since of course
radclip wasn't able to wear contacts
as with all the films they aren't
entirely consistent with what's written
in the novels
one of the more notable changes in this
movie was of course
the purple hair tonks has instead of the
signature pink she's described as having
in the novel
the team felt pink was too associated
with dolores
umbridge and didn't want there to be any
connections between the two characters
the purple hairdo took about 30 minutes
to prepare every single day with part of
her real hair that had been dyed
as well as a purple lace wig that she
had on another change was creature being
included in the movie
while his role isn't huge it was
important enough to add to the script
after jk rowling insisted he be included
in order for
other scenes that needed to happen in
future to make sense
all his scenes were actually added after
the principal shooting
then of course how could we forget nigel
well if you've only read the books then
you absolutely wouldn't know who nigel
is since
he was a character created just for the
movie without any mention in the book
series
as for the characters that were in the
novels the bellatrix lestrange we got in
the movies was almost played by another
actress pretty close to home
helen mccrory was originally set to play
bellatrix but
after learning she was pregnant the role
went to helena bonham carter
luckily we did get to meet her later on
as narcissa malfoy
both roles are pretty impeccably cast in
the end
protect him from home we still
aren't over the fact that the weasley
twins are not only real life
but serious tricksters the reason for
harry's scream being silenced
absolutely breaks our heart we can't
imagine what it was like to see that
live on set
what was your favorite behind the scenes
fact